HANNU RAJANIEMI: Hello,
everybody.
My name is Hannu Rajaniemi.
I'm very pleased to be here,
and very glad to
see so many of you.
I'm assuming you are here
because you know at least some
of my work.
So I guess I'm mainly known as
the author of the novels "The
Quantum Thief," and the
"Freckled Prince," and the
forthcoming "Causal Angel."
If you don't know
that, I'm also a
recovering string theorist.
At the moment, I'm trying
to get over it, honest.
I keep falling back.
Also, at the moment, attending
one of your friendly
neighbors, the Singularity
University, doing some fun
things with my teammates
at the moment with DNA.
Can't say too much about
that at the moment.
But what I wanted to talk about
today with you is the
future of books--
obviously, a subject that I
care about very deeply.
And I'll try to talk about it
not necessarily from the point
of view of e-books and
e-publishing and things like
that, but how the form of the
book itself changed as the way
we create and read
books changes.
And I think we have quite
a bit of time, so
I'll start with that.
And then I will also read a
short story, which is related
to the themes that I'm
going to talk about.
And then also feel free
to interrupt any
time with any questions.
And we should have plenty
of time for those
later on, as well.
So I guess the first question
is, where does one glimpse the
future of books and the obvious
answer is, in a book,
and specifically speaking, a
book that begins like this.
"It was the day my grandmother
exploded." If you're not
familiar with that book,
it's "The Crow
Road," by Iain Banks.
So sadly, recently he
passed away after a
short battle with cancer.
But it's one of my
favorite books.
And it's certainly one of the
great lines in all of
literature.
And I read it for the first time
back in 1998, so almost
15 years ago, back when I was
still living in Finland, where
I'm originally from.
And I picked it up because, like
probably many of you, I
mainly knew Iain Banks as the
author of the Culture novels--
so these utopian space operas
set in this society called the
Culture, which is ruled
over by Ray Kurzweil--
sorry--
super intelligent artificial
minds.
So I was drawn to
this particular
the book by the author.
But it actually turned out to be
a very different novel from
the Culture books.
So if you haven't read it,
it's about a young man's
attempts to deal with his
complicated family history and
this labyrinth of sex and death
and the disappearance of
his eccentric uncle Rory, who
leaves behind this mysterious
manuscript that then the main
character, Prentice, tries to
piece together to figure out
what happened to his uncle, as
well as all kinds of weird and
fun stuff related to his
family history.
So if you haven't read it,
I highly recommend it.
But the reason I mention it was
that it really spoke to me
when I read it.
It had to do, obviously, with
the fact that the main
character was also in his 20s,
in this state of confusion,
trying to find his
way in the world.
And also, Banks is a wonderful,
wonderful stylist
and writer of prose.
So it also described Scotland,
which for me, at the time, was
kind of this strange, almost
science fictional landscape
that enhanced all the strange
things happening in the story.
And it is about death.
"The crow road" is actually
a Glaswegian
expression for death.
To take the crow road
means to die.
And there is a lot of
death in the book.
But at its heart, it's tells you
that things are going to
be OK, and these difficult
things can be dealt with.
And then a few months ago, I
happened to pick it up again.
Motivated by the news of Iain
Banks' illness, I wanted to
revisit some of his work.
And I read it again.
And what really, really struck
me was that what I read the
second time felt like a totally
different book, like a
completely different book.
First of all, the simple aspect
was that, at that
point, I'd been living in
Scotland for quite a while.
So all the sort of evocative
imagery that Banks has about
ruined castles, and clouds over
Highland Islands, and
sunsets, and things like that, I
could really visualize them.
I could smell the heather and
really be there much more
powerfully than I could
have been before.
And I also finally got all the
sex jokes, because there's
quite a few of them in there.
And also the philosophy and
attitude of growth felt
totally different.
So it was a very powerful
experience to read it again.
But what it made me really think
about was that, where
was the book?
What was the book?
I've always thought of books
as these containers,
permanent, eternal containers,
for the
thoughts of the author.
And then I guess, as a writer,
there's a little bit of wish
fulfillment for some sort of
authorial immortality.
At least, even if I'm mortal,
some of my ideas will survive.
But actually, if my "Crow Road"
15 years ago was totally
different from my "Crow Road" of
today, where was the book?
It felt like some sort of
quantum mechanical,
observer-dependent thing,
where depending on how I
measure my quantum object,
it collapses
into a different state.
And then that really begged the
question of what are books?
Where do they come from?
And what is our relationship
with them?
And what is bookness?
And I think it's a
very important
question to ask today.
Because we are in this area
where books are becoming even
more ephemeral, quite literally
intangible, turning
into bits, something you
guys are extremely
well familiar with.
So there is this process of
dematerialization happening
with books.
So what can we do with
books in their
future intangible state?
Are they going to disappear?
Or are they going to become
something completely different?
So I started looking into what
people were saying about the
future of books.
And obviously, a lot of people
have been thinking about this.
And there's a lot of research
going on on
the future of books.
And one of the more interesting
things I've found
was a scenario forecasting
exercise by the design company
IDEA, which we've had some
interactions with at
Singularity University.
And I'm sure you're familiar
with them.
And they came up with three
quite interesting scenarios
named after different literary
inspirations.
So the first scenario they
came up with was called
Coupland, after Douglas
Coupland, author of
"Generation X" and "Microserfs."
And anyone who's
not familiar with "Microserfs--"
required
reading for anybody who wants to
get involved in a startup.
And the Coupland scenario is
based on the idea that books
are going to become more social,
and publishing is
going to become more social.
It's all going to be about who
reads what in our social
network, what sort of
recommendations are made based
on that, discussion around
books, and even things like,
as part of the scenario, if a
sufficient number of people in
your social network buys a
certain book, you will
automatically get access
to it as well.
So even the business models
around books in this scenario
are going to be very
socially driven.
The second scenario, which they
call Nelson, after Ted
Nelson, the pioneer of
hypertext, is based on the
idea that it's all about
annotation and being able to
refer back to who is actually
talking about your book-- who
is quoting it?
What are the sources
of the book?
Can you verify them?
Can you generate more discussion
around them?
So it's about annotation and
bi-directional links--
so turning books into very
different kinds of objects.
And finally, which is maybe
the most obvious one, or
natural one, considering the
growth of computer games--
Alice.
Turning books into more game
like-- so Choose Your Own
Adventure-style--
things, or with more media rich
content, and essentially
merging them with
computer games.
Obviously, these are not
the only possibilities.
There are others like Nick
Montfort and Neil Gaiman, who
recently created exercises where
book-like things are
authored collaboratively using
wiki-style systems.
So you can see that people are
thinking about how the role of
the reader, the author, the
publishing industry, how that
is going to change
with technology.
But the more I read about
these things, the more
unsatisfying I found them.
There was something missing
about all these scenarios.
And it took me quite a while
until I could really put my
finger on it.
But what I started to feel was
that really the core thing
about my engagement with "The
Crow Road" and any other book
I read what was the deep
immersion, allowing yourself
to be led into this waking
dream where you spend a
certain period of time.
And maybe that dream is
different at different times
when you read the book.
But there is this real sense of
letting go of yourself and
sinking into the book into
a dreamlike state.
And so of course, that's
something that neuroscientists
have studied.
And in 2009, there was a very
interesting study by Nicole
Speer, at University of
Washington, where they
actually looked at a lot of
people reading in an FMRI
machine and tried to understand
what was going on
in their brains as they
were reading.
And what they found was that
reading really is not a
passive thing at all.
It's not just consuming and
taking in information.
It's actually virtually enacting
the situations that
you read about.
So when you read about a certain
action, the same parts
of your brain that would
actually activate in real life
if you were to carry out that
action become engaged.
There's this mental simulation
of virtual reality that we
construct after reading
a book.
And obviously, those simulations
are shaped by our
own experience, as well.
But it's a very, very
deep engagement.
And it probably has to do with
the fact that in order to
read, we've re-purposed some
very fundamental pattern,
symbol, recognition machinery
in our brains that really go
to very primal layers.
So actually, what books are,
from that point of view,
they're information brain
interface technologies.
You could almost call
them brain computer
interfaces in some way.
So then can we to look at books
from that point of view,
and what can we learn?
To take a step back briefly,
books haven't
always been this powerful.
And I'm trying to get to my next
slide, which would show
an example of that.
There we go.
So actually books, in their
current form are a relatively
recent thing.
Reading silently is a relatively
new thing.
Reading used to mean
reading aloud.
This is an example of medieval
script called scriptura
continua, where there
are no word spaces.
And so in order to distinguish
the different words and to
make sense of the text, you
would actually have to have to
read it aloud very slowly
and carefully.
So it was very difficult to get
this immersion the state
happening that I was talking
about earlier.
And it was only with technology,
with the printing
press and typography and also
more software-like technology
like grammar and spelling
conventions and things like
that that we actually managed
to refine books in to their
current form.
And I don't think it's a
coincidence that the novel,
which is the current highest
form of fiction, if you like,
or regarded as such, came around
around the same time as
the printing press decided
to become popular.
So from this point
of view, what
could we do to go further?
So what would be the next step
beyond what we have now if we
start using technologies which
are more powerful than just
typography.
Well, I think one part of the
answer is something you guys
at Google know a lot about,
which is gathering information
about the reader.
So in Soviet Russia,
the book reads you.
[LAUGHING]
HANNU RAJANIEMI: And again, I
don't have to tell you about
all the technologies we now
have to gather information
about how we interact with
a piece of content.
So I'm sure you know all about
my online reading behavior.
But now we also have devices
like this one.
So it's an Emotiv EEG headset,
a simple commercial device
that allows a user's brain
activity to be--
relatively low fidelity, but
still allows it to be recorded
wirelessly while they're doing
something, whatever that is.
And in case you follow these
things, Emotiv just a few days
ago announced a next generation,
much shinier,
cyberpunkish, stylish version
of this device.
So that's possible.
Samsung, I believe, is already
experimenting with a
thought-controlled tablet.
Another thing which is
relatively easy to do today is
eye tracking, looking at where a
users eyes move on the page.
That's also a technology that's
going to be probably
integrate into tablets and
mobile phones pretty soon.
I'm sure you can neither confirm
nor deny anything
about future incarnations of
Google Glass, but it's not
beyond the boundaries of
imagination to assume that
some form of either eye tracking
or brain interfaces
or things like that could
feature there as well.
And given that, now,
increasingly, the devices that
have this power to gather this
information are the same
devices we use to read.
Then future books will
literally have the
power to read us.
So what would those
books be like?
What could we do with
this power?
From the point of view of a
writer, the interesting
question is always, if you have
a new technology, what
stories can you tell with it?
And it's maybe a bit too early
to say what's possible, but
there are few interesting
examples of
things in this direction.
So the BBC has been
experimenting with something
called perceptive media.
A friend of mine there, Ian
Forrester, at BBC R&D,
produced a radio play called
"Breaking Out," which adapts
the story a little bit based
on what information the app
can gather about the user.
It's very simple things.
There are a few locations and
pubs and places like that are
mentioned in the story.
And those are customized for
each user given what
information can be gathered
about their
location and interests.
So just in order to deliver a
more powerful emotional punch
and a closer connection
to the story.
Now, of course, you could be
much more ambitious than that.
If we stay on the subject of
actual books rather than other
types of content, could we
imagine a book that rewrites
itself for every reader, or
perhaps for every reading.
And a good science fictional
example of that, of course, is
A Young Lady's Illustrated
Primer, this personalized
teaching device featured in Neal
Stephenson's "The Diamond
Age."
And in fact, there is a spin-out
project from the One
Laptop Per Child project called
Nell, named after the
protagonist of "The Diamond
Age," which is trying to do
exactly that.
So they are trying to create a
system that can engage with a
learning child by generating
these personalized,
tailor-made fairy tales, where
the reader is the protagonist.
So that's quite interesting.
It's early days for that sort
of thing, but it's probably
going to happen sooner
or later.
So on a personal note,
my friend Sam, Sam
[? Halliday ?], also a
recovering mathematician and a
data scientist.
We wanted to do a little
prototype of what we could
imagine, or a very simple toy
model of what we could
imagine, a future
book to be like.
So this year we create a project
called Neurofiction,
which you can have a look at
online, which is essentially a
story you read on a computer
screen while wearing one of
these devices.
And the story changes
in response
to your brain activity.
So the idea was to not really
make it a Choose Your Own
Adventure story, but to retain
this kind of linear, immersive
experience and just give the
user the same kind of
experience that they have with
traditional fiction, but
underneath have the software and
the interaction of their
brains with the text
drive the story.
So the current story is called
"Snow White Is Dead." It's a
retelling of the fairytale
I'm sure you all know.
And the way it works is that in
the beginning of the story,
we expose the user to some
verbal imagery associated to
first, life, and then death.
And then for each subsequent
scene, we measure their
response to those scenes.
So are they closer
to life or death.
And that takes them down, I
think, 48 possible different
parts, with two very
different endings.
And we ran this recently at
the Edinburgh Science
Festival, and we got a lot of
very, very positive feedback.
So obviously this was a very
primitive experiment.
But it seems possible to create
narratives that really
do, on some level, directly
engage with the user's brain.
And we've actually open-sourced
all the
code that we wrote.
So if you have an Emotiv device,
or hopefully we'll
update it for the new Emotiv
device, you can download it
and play with it and try
to create your own
neurofiction as well.
So just to conclude,
obviously it's hard
to predict the future.
So none of these technological
innovations I've mentioned
might survive for very long,
or might be replaced by
something we can't
yet imagine.
But I do believe that a book
itself, and fiction, are quite
robust against change.
And there's a lot of them that
we love that I think is worth
preserving.
But I do very much like the
idea of a book that is not
just a receptacle for the
thoughts of the author, but
also preserves the experience of
the reader in some way, so
that through devices like
the Emotiv or its future
incarnations, we get some sort
of emotional marginalia
preserved between the
pages of the book.
So sort of like this quote
from Argentinian writer
Alberto Manguel, which
is underlined here.
"Implicit in the possession of
a book is the history of a
book's previous readings.
Every new reader is affected by
what he or she imagines the
book to have been in
previous hands."
So with a little bit of
technology, we could make that
literally true.
And so future books could retain
echoes of the people we
used to be when we
first read them.
I mentioned that neuroscience
has shown that when we read,
we actually become the book.
But perhaps, given a bit
of time, future books
could become us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I'm curious about
this notion of yours about
becoming the thing that
you're reading.
I understand I think
a little bit of the
neuroscience behind it.
But what do I become when I'm
reading about matrix algebra?
HANNU RAJANIEMI: [CHUCKLES]
AUDIENCE: You see
what I'm saying?
There's a whole category
of books I don't
know what that means.
HANNU RAJANIEMI: No.
No, I completely agree.
Of course, I am mainly talking
about fiction here.
And I think fiction has
something of a unique ability
to get us to identify with other
people and get us to
feel what it's like
to be them.
No, there are obviously
categories of--
some non-fictional books with
a narrative structure can do
that as well.
But you're right-- an
engagement, if it's something
like mathematics, is completely
different.
I guess there, also, the
slowness and destruction-free
nature of the experience is
quite important though--
so to have something that helps
you engage with it.
And I think even there, some
sort of technology that would
monitor your state of
concentration could actually
be quite helpful.
AUDIENCE: My question is, with
this, isn't this going to be
putting a huger burden on the
author to be able to be
creating multiple paths
of his story?
And how much does it then start
becoming, maybe, author
by committee?
Because you've got to have
multiple people in there to do
all the different options.
HANNU RAJANIEMI: No, that's an
extremely good questions.
So for example, working on
this Snow White story I
mentioned, initially the idea
was to have it a lot more like
Choose Your Own Adventure
stories.
But what I actually started to
feel was that I actually had a
slight problem with multiple
branching narratives.
Because the thing about good
fiction is that the ending of
the story is very important.
And that ending has to be
somehow both surprising and
inevitable.
And that inevitability has to
arise from the character and
all the interactions with
the characters.
So if you want to write
stories with radically
different, multiple endings, the
characters themselves have
to be quite different.
And so you do get this huge
cognitive burden dealing with
that and some sort of
combinatorial explosion.
So I'm not necessarily saying
that you always have to have
multiple branching narratives.
And it's interesting what the
BBC guys, for example, have
set as their goal for perceptive
media, which is not
necessarily have multiple
conclusions or endings, but
just along the way put slightly
different emphasis on
different things, depending on
what the sort of measured
preferences or whatever
we know about the
viewer or reader is.
So I think that approach might
actually be a bit more
scalable and still allow some
degree of authorial control,
which of course, writers
guard very jealously.
So yeah, a very good question.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering how will
you be able to discuss a
book, like, say, come up
to somebody and say,
hey, I read this book.
And they read a totally
different thing.
Or if you want to write
a report on it.
So I think any sort
of discussion
will be really confused.
What's your opinion on that?
HANNU RAJANIEMI: But that might
also make it a lot more
interesting.
Even now with books, I think
people discover different
things than other readers.
It really depends
on how radically
you allow it to change.
If it's all generated by an
artificial intelligence based
on some measurements that it
makes in the reader's brain,
then you right.
It could be completely
different.
But I don't know.
That should lead to richer and
more interesting discussions.
And of course, the two
individuals in question might
have the ability to compare
their respective versions and
see where they diverge.
AUDIENCE: A lot of these issues
are being dealt with
right now in video games,
constructing these branching
narratives where you can maybe
even choose the gender of your
character from the beginning
of the story, and that has
ramifications throughout the
rest of the long arc of the
video game, or maybe even
over multiple games.
Especially also when you talk
about things like MMOs, and
you have multiple different
people interacting, but you're
also trying to construct a
narrative in that space that's
shared amongst all
those people.
So it's not really a question,
but just do you have any
insights into that space or how
this interacts with what
you were talking about?
HANNU RAJANIEMI: No, it's
very, very related.
Mu third novel, "The Causal
Angel," actually deals quite a
bit with games.
And so in order to do research
for it, I actually bought an
Xbox and played "Batman: Arkham
City" quite a bit.
[LAUGHS]
But it's absolutely fascinating
what people are
doing in the context of computer
games and branching
storytelling and role
playing and so on.
But I haven't yet quite
found a way--
or I don't know of a computer
game where the narrative
experience and identification
with a character is as deep as
it is in fiction.
And I wonder, at least using
the current generation of
computer games, if
it can ever be.
In the area of games, the domain
where I personally had
such experience in the gaming
context has been in tabletop
and live role playing
games with very
strong narrative elements.
So I'm not saying the
convergence of these the two
things is impossible.
But for the purposes of this
discussion, I was really
focusing on more how could we
enhance this experience of
sitting down and
reading a book.
But again, very, very
good point.
AUDIENCE: I was curious if you
tried using any of the Emotive
technology while you were trying
to write any of these
stories as well.
So I wonder if eventually you'd
start having a profile
between the author and the
readers so that you can start
suggesting things based off
of someone with a similar
pattern, or if you had done
anything with that already.
HANNU RAJANIEMI:
We did actually
think about that idea.
Although, with the current
technology, the limitations
are pretty serious.
But yeah, we did have this idea
actually with a robotics
researcher in Edinburgh
University that maybe we could
have an underlying-- a
generative model of text.
You guys have huge, huge engrams
and things like that
that we could use to generate
text, and then measure the
brain response of the
author in this case.
For example, there's a very
nice signal in the brain
called P300, which activates
when you see something that
really interests you or
you find surprising.
So you could actually maybe
use this signal to train a
genetic algorithm to generate
text that you somehow like or
find interesting.
But I think you'd have to put
quite a lot of thought into
how to constrain that to
make it interesting.
There's a startup in Chile,
which is using a very similar
technique to allow
schoolchildren to create 3D
models of monsters.
So they're evolving 3D models
of monsters and steering the
utility function of the
algorithm based on what they
measure in the brain.
But the current generation,
we realize, is very noisy.
So I think it's effectively
random.
But yeah, very interesting
idea.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious if you had
any ideas instead of maybe
a book being more pleasurable to
someone or finding out what
somebody prefers, maybe writing
a book that really
antagonizes someone, or
pushes them out of
their comfort zone.
HANNU RAJANIEMI: Yeah, no, that
was actually what we were
aiming for with the
Snow White story.
So it wasn't really necessarily
about their
comfort zone.
We actually tried to take them
in directions that they
wouldn't expect.
So I guess that then it really
becomes like fiction already
is to a large extent.
Actually, a wonderful example of
that is Iain Banks's first
novel, "The Wasp Factory," which
is a fantastic fictional
experience, but very, very,
very unpleasant.
So, yeah, absolutely, you could
equally well use these
kinds of techniques for
engineering a certain
emotional trajectory or path
that you want to take the
reader through.
And there, it becomes almost
like a control problem.
And there, there is an element
of authorial design.
So if you feel that the user
is straying away from this
path that you've designed, you
try to the push them with new
content back on track
with that.
AUDIENCE: Is there a way that
you've thought to engage the
reader in some analysis of
the book after the fact?
So in regular books, we have
discussion questions, perhaps,
at the end.
But is there some new thoughts
of engaging the reader in
literary analysis along the
way, or at the end?
HANNU RAJANIEMI: So I confess,
I'm quite ignorant of the
practice and techniques
of literary criticism.
But one idea we had, which we
partially implemented, but
it's not really in the current
version, was to actually give
the user a heat map of the story
based on the regions
depending on which direction
their reaction had swung in
different parts.
So to highlight to them
what parts had
been the most engaging.
I actually did a little bit of
experimentation with Sam on
this just by reading a large
variety of fiction and looking
at things which engaged us.
They were quite different for
me and Sam, and obviously
different types of engagement.
A lot of very rich stylists
actually, we found, created an
awful lot of activity in the
back electrodes of the device,
which is associated with
the visual region.
So clearly we were getting
a lot of visual images.
But I'm sure there could be a
much richer engagement between
the neural experience--
and actually, for me as an
author, it would be really
interesting to see what sort
of sections of the text and
style provoke the actions
of the readers.
Thank yoiu.
[APPLAUSE]